l'homme orchestre c'est quoi le mort
qu'est ce qu est un film je dirige en
valais c'est ça je dirais un balai et un
ballet de danseuses ou jeu loué une
villa pour elle je les surveille sans
arrêt pour qu'il n'y ait pas de fleurs
tenir hier lui manque
simplement mon neveu qui s'appelle
philippe bon qui en réalité d'olivier de
finesse et mon fils il a le pouvoir est
très très extrêmement sympathique wiland
tout le monde connaît est ce que moi je
rentre c'est tout le monde est rétracté
il faut que je gagne mois sur une scène
il faut que je gagne vraiment de mon
talent quand j'arrive il ya trois
applaudissements puis c'est tout les
faux j'ai moins cinq dix minutes à
gagner public puisque lui je suis sûr
qu'il arrive place c'est gagner comme
fernandel comme bourvil
c'est gagné il ya des komi france
reviennent ça c'est pas gagné du tout je
suis timide j'ai peur je suis rentré je
suis inquiet en plus il joue de la
batterie c'est un très beau très
formateur celui qui joue dans ce film la
batterie déjà séduit sa cellule vous
avez été des années pianiste et j'ai
tapé sur la com votre maison en termes
techniques dans des bars dans les
bistrots le soir la nuit dans les bars
américains je viens te jure je voulus
montée de marches une petite marche à
chaque fille salir une ligne de plus à y
a rien à faire je les gouttes et moi il
faut que je monte alors une ligne de
plus et puis vous me donner 500 en plus
quand même maintenant fait le format
même pour moi c'est pour mon plaisir ou
même 200 francs alors une donnée je t'ai
toujours montre toujours j'ai fait une
petite montée j'étais pousser vos
caméras
tous et malgré moi faire le détail c'est
bon à lire et vous parce que je ne
voulais pas je voulais rester second
plan vous ne pleurez pas quand même
d'être l'un des comiques le plus à
l'aise devant vous si ça donne des
responsabilités quand même
mais quelle machine faut pas décevoir et
puis alors je dépends de trop de gens je
détendent mettant ce jeu dépend de celui
qui met clé je dépends que le
distributeur je dépends du producteur et
c'est pourquoi je voudrais bien a pu
réunir tout ça et me mettre avec un bon
scénariste et puis me mettre aussi à
écrire et plus dé faire moi même un jeu
génie toujours s'amuse pas que l'année
prochaine ça va voir le jour assure le
metteur en scène quand une vieille idée
comics je peux pas la tournée faut que
je lui vers l'atlantique alors je lui
raconte
en général il comprend pas tout de suite
alors vous avez raconté à notre beau en
faisant des gestes qui alors nous on ne
s'habille pas enlevé le 8 juin moi je
suis fatigué au moment de la tournée ne
déjà joué trois fois c'est à dire et
c'était à moi je besoin de mal à jouer
on dit les comics sont tristes vous êtes
tristes nous
non parce qu'on s'attend ce que les
comics soit toujours attendre rigoler
c'est ce que disait sacha guitry train
de faire des pirouettes désir des mots
d'esprit sans honorer mes ciseaux qu'un
comique mangin vittek normalement disent
qu'il est triste sont avides une formule
qui marche comme ceux qui souhaitent de
multiples sur la tête
la sas et ça serait vraiment un comique